I grew up in a culture that was very
verbal and argumentative we had a saying
10 Jews 11 opinions I that was part of
the culture there were constant
good-natured arguments around the table
with friends and relatives and parents
but I think in addition the 1960s seemed
like a time when everything was up for
grabs you could ask questions like
couldn't we have a society without money
do we really need the government or even
will cash be obsolete could we outlaw
war questions that seem to heart back to
to the Enlightenment when you had
thinkers trying to rationalize the very
basis for society in the 60s it seemed
to be okay to ask those questions again
I wasn't part of the 60s movement I was
too young but it filtered down to to my
circles because we had older brothers
and you read about it in the papers and
saw it on TV so is there just a time in
which everything seemed up for grabs
people often ask me how my parents
influenced me and I can't give a neutral
answer to that because I very much
influenced by saying by hans eysenck
that the biggest influence that parents
have on their children is at the moment
of conception I think that the people
often attribute far too much to parental
upbringing and there's a fair amount of
data from my field that not widely known
that suggests that the effect of pay of
parents in shaping intellect and
personality might even be overrated you
see this in children of immigrants even
if their parents had never acquired the
language and culture of the adopted
country as long as the kids were
immersed in a a peer group they end up
as fully competent citizens something
indeed that happened to my own father
the children of immigrants who were
culturally utterly inept never managed
to speak the language in the case of my
grandmother were constantly at sea and
figuring out the culture and my father
grew up highly successful so if you
would ask the question of him how did
your parents shape you he would have
laughed he shaped himself I don't want
to deny credit to my parents who brought
me up in a rich and stimulating
household but I think I'd be kind of
inventing a novelistic autobiography
which is I think what most people do
when asked how did your parents
influence you that having been said it
was a house with with books with
discussion with arguments with people
coming in and challenging us with
interesting ideas so I wouldn't have
traded it for it for anything but the
scientist in me says that warns against
my own tendency to tell a story and how
it explained Who I am today
I think it's more being immersed in you
know the world of ideas in general one
thing that my parents who did that did
influence me was buy an encyclopedia
which I read almost cover to cover
they also subscribe to many magazines
which I would devour I think most people
even though it makes a good novelistic
story to hold up a role model or a
mentor or an influence I would have to
say that it was just immersing myself in
a huge sea of ideas that led me to my
current worldview there are some things
that were influential at different parts
of my adult professional career I was
certainly influenced by Noam Chomsky my
former colleague at MIT and by a number
of the other founders of the the so
called cognitive revolution in the 1950s
George Miller Gerald Bruner Roger brown
who was one of my graduates for school
mentors herb Simon and Alan Newell
Marvin Minsky they people who first came
up with the idea that thinking is a form
of information processing or computation
almost allowing us to get a grasp on one
aspect of the mind-body problem how
could a physical device result in
intelligence probably the other major
influence was from evolutionary biology
from the founders of the revolution and
evolutionary biology that took place in
the 1960s people like Robert rivers
George Williams John Maynard Smith
William Hamilton who we thought the
nature of evolution and how complex
adaptations could arise from the process
of selection among replicators mainly
genes
falta to credit who you are with your
parents it seems like an act of of
decency or gratitude and in fact I often
have to apologize to my parents saying I
really do appreciate everything you did
to me it's just that the scientific data
lead me to think that parents don't
shape children as much as most people
think and their attitude is I should
give them credit for their attitude
which is we would want you to say
anything but what you believe based on
the best scientific evidence that that
you take seriously so don't try to
fashion your answer to have to flatter
us I think that that is a sign of the
kind of people that they are they are I
think as interested in ideas and in
providing good reasons for your ideas as
I am I don't know whether I inherited
that whether they fostered it in me but
they deserve full credit for that
even if perhaps by the standards of
their friends I seem to be denying them
credit and in talking about theories of
the shaping of personality
I remember my
my mentor Roger Brown was saying he was
one of the founders of the study of
child language acquisition which is what
a lot of my own research has been
focused on he said you know you'll never
really understand what children are
doing this was a bit of an ironic
comment because of course that's what he
spent his life doing you know what I've
dedicated much of my life to doing but
it is uh it does offer a little bit of
of humility and a feeling that if you
don't quite understand everything that's
in your data you shouldn't feel too bad
about it it's extraordinarily complex
we're fortunate to understand what we do
understand I've gotten advice on writing
from or the editor of mine who said when
you try to present science to a wide
audience don't feel that you're writing
for truck drivers or or chicken pluckers
they probably realistically won't buy
your book and if you try to aim at
everyone you'll end up talking down or
condescending right for your college
roommate someone who you respect as
being as smart as you
they went into a different line of work
they're joining the conversation late
they need to be brought up to speed but
assume that your audiences is as
intellectually engaged as smart as you
are that was terrific advice both for
teaching and for writing and speaking
for a wide audience